[Music]
and jordan is still alive today he's not
uh
you know he's still with us if you had
to ask him something one question you
had to ask jordan today what would that
be
well i see fp quite a bit we were at
watch week in dubai just a few weeks ago
i was with him in california i'm part of
the groupie band of collectors that
meets up with him
i'm always interested in what's next
because this guy is a genius and he he
sits around the pool at a watch show or
he was once in las vegas and he he
dripped up the uh
you know the astronaut meek a million
dollar watch he makes one of a kind for
each individual collector they are
incredibly coveted the way you have to
look at collecting jordan is imagine if
you knew the value of picasso and you
personally knew picasso while he was
alive and he would paint a picasso for
you can you imagine what that would be
like that's exactly what's happening
with jordan right now yeah everybody i
know that's a collector calls me says
kevin we know you know fp is there any
way you can get me an fpjorn and that
journey is about forming a relationship
with the brand it always is you know
it's like a roger smith it's like ap
which now you have to have your own
account with them to buy
they're managing their brand masterfully
and it's your benefit because your
pieces appreciate in value the minute
you walk out of the store with them uh
you're a dial guy and i know you know
you you that's something that you look
at when choosing something for your
collection i want to bring up two or
three brands that are a little bit out
there when it comes to dials richard
mill and jacobs and co how do you feel
about these
you know i i know them both um i i saw
jacob at um
at watch week he had a spectacular booth
he was showing some of his most eclectic
pieces
they are really beautifully made and
these are high art that's what they are
um i don't own either of them actually i
do own i do on one jacob a a beautiful
piece i have that because it's it's a
gorgeous red dial that works so well on
shark tank
the the high-end pieces are really
jewelry combined with
you know a sound understanding of
horological development so the creation
of the timepiece itself
it's a little different than the
direction i go in collecting um i love
them there's no question uh mill is a is
a whole different kettle of fish i mean
the the
the actual size of the dial and the
piece itself and the weight of it is an
acquired taste i do not own any richard
nails right now i've been looking at
them for two to three years that's not
unusual for me i've been talking to the
brand
um
it is very very successful it is
extremely coveted within the crypto
crowd bitcoin 2022 will be in february
here meal will undoubtedly have a
boutique
right at the bitcoin show
because so many people but that style of
watch mill is a pioneer in that style
let me show you a company that is doing
something similar
yes this is a vanity an australian
entrepreneurial group this is a giant
chunk of sapphire with a skeleton
tourbillon inside it this is a beautiful
piece
um
this actually
is a one of a kind
it's mr wonderful
it has a black and red band obviously
again you know this is the kind of of
style where you're getting a very very
large dial you're making a statement uh
it's extremely creative but to be made
out of sapphire these watches
sell for hundreds of thousands of
dollars however this entrepreneurial
group has figured out a way to bring
them to the market in more of the 12 15
20 000 range and less
so i really i really appreciate this
kind of artistry being made affordable
and i have uh several of these pieces
from avanti
but but you're right these are these are
more on the modern art they call them
the andy warhols
and they deserve a place in your
collection but these these are when you
start to extend into the micro brands i
was going to mention we were talking
about dials um
speaking about micro brands every once
in a while within the collector
community i'll get a phone call
you know i used to think i had the
world's largest watch collection until i
went to the united arab emirates
i'm a nothing burger compared to what
those guys are doing and i've and i've
met some of them in fact i think i've
met the largest watch collector in the
world
um he we become very close friends and
he's he's one of the royal family um
he called me up and said have you ever
heard of a
ming
i said i've never heard of him
he said this brand is getting smoking
hot out of singapore ming is a
photographer artist he designs dials and
he makes his movements in switzerland
this is a ming
this beautiful floating dial
is unique with this incredible skeleton
you know crystal in the back to see the
movement but what matters about this
meeting is
ming makes very few watches but he
decided to make one of a kind ming for
himself
ming's me
and
i learned about the brand through my ui
connection i emailed the company the
production manager came back and said my
goodness kevin we love shark tank in
singapore
are you going to be wearing the the ming
you buy on shark tank i said i don't
know i have to go through wardrobe
and it's going to need a red band
anyways okay and he said to me look
ming is willing to give you the ming
ming made for me you'll get ming's me
you're going to have to pay more for it
you'll have the only main ever made in
the world for me
it'll be a one of a kind here it is
what's special about that one why is it
one of a kind
he made a one-of-a-kind case for himself
of a very very extreme medal here and so
it was designed for him to wear on his
wrist as means me
yeah when a maker gives you an honor
like that
this is a this is an incredible piece in
my collection and and so i talk about
this story and again here we are a dial
is creating a story that's what great
watch collecting is about each watch has
a story that's the whole point if
somebody were to buy a collection for
themselves
with the mentality of having an
investment portfolio of watches what are
some of the top brands you would
recommend
rolex very collectible okay really good
investment particularly
incredibly good investment you can't go
wrong with attack uh i do more pk ap
absolutely i mean i'm wearing uh the
5911 right now as my chosen piece for
the second for lunch today this was this
came into the market a couple of years
ago i got one of the first hundred made
it was not widely appreciated but either
was the original um ap we talked about
the design the royal oak when it came
out
if you're offered the first of the first
of a new model you have to take it
because over time it will always be one
of the first 100s and of course it's
appreciated in value i was going to
mention
um
you know patek
they just stopped making the 5711.
this coveted piece
it almost doubled in value on that
announcement on that press announcement
5711
you can no longer get one
is probably the most coveted patek right
now it's steel but it's a classic
so
the value has gone up dramatically and
you mentioned earlier probably the most
unappreciated brand in the world
grand seiko the quality of these watches
this is a grand sacral lacquer special
edition of 100
you cannot the crunch when you duck when
you just
actually wind it the crunch is legendary
the quality of these is equal to a patek
philippe if you're going to start this
is a great brand to start in grand
patech because you're getting such value
absolutely spectacular
i was going to mention another break so
many brands longines is making amazing
watches absolutely gorgeous here's
another called the superman
seiko a beautiful starter watch
beautiful blue dial incredible polishing
i mean look don't get me going as they
say i could go all day you want to go
login you want to go um grand seiko no
question about it those are baselines
you want it there's some omega pieces
you can dabble in you can go to the
vintage market and look for other pieces
i mean i'm just i'm just purveying you
know some of the watches i brought out
of the safe here we've looked at almost
all of them
the the key to this though is
do not buy a watch that you cannot
afford
buy a watch that you fall in love with
right and wait for that opportunity
start to appreciate the pursuit of
horology the pursuit of dials the
pursuit of storytelling but right now
i did a shoot with teddy recently at a
long june boutique here in miami and i
saw dials that company which is not as
well known in north america is huge in
asia makes incredible watches and
extremely affordable prices
i mean same with with grand seiko
remember there's seiko and there's grand
seiko and seiko you can get entry-level
pieces in there and they're absolutely
spectacular the superman i just showed
you
start in in places like that omega the
swatch group
i mean
you you can't go wrong and and bulova
you know there's vintage pieces american
watch company i own them all i mean i
and i i don't i don't chase price i
chase dial i want that's what i am
that's what i like about you as a
collector because you don't you're not a
watch stop you don't just go for the
higher end stuff you buy things that
appeal to you
on a personal level and you have the
entire spectrum of watches i want to end
the conversation on on japanese watches
because you mentioned grants i'm wearing
by myself i love it this is a spring
drive gmt and when i first got the watch
i i set it to my phone
and two weeks later it was still running
perfectly to the second
to my phone do you know another watch
that has that level of accuracy that is
also a mechanical watch kevin
very few very very few the history of
grand seiko very few people know this
but
they were one of the very first makers
of watches it grew out of the lock
industry and japan
started making fine watch pieces before
the swiss
and in the in the 70s when they had
these contests to test accuracy in
switzerland the japanese one year after
year after year and it manifests itself
in the grand seiko heritage those spring
drives are incredible pieces the
technology inside of that watch is is
the best on earth in some ways in terms
of what they've developed there and they
keep getting better the accuracy is
insane but the other thing about them is
they covet the design of the dial they
have beautiful contrast on those dials
and the polishing of the steel and the
other precious metals is off the charts
so i you know i can't say enough about
them
i have many many grand seikos now uh and
i consider them to be some of the finest
pieces i own but
you know they they they are the swiss
kind of have the biggest branding but in
terms of quality you can't go wrong with
the grand seiko and some of the other
brands we've talked about i mean watch
collecting is um is it a disease
it's a virus yeah it's very expensive
um
uh you know it's
my wife is really pissed at me because i
keep coming home with watches and she
says what are you crazy i'm gonna get
you help this is insane you ca you're
wearing three to four watches a day and
you still can't get into your collection
in a year it's insane if you like that
video wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe